this is our only chance
we have to take it
[Music]
we need calm the world needs him
to stop what's coming
and this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go
so i made a promise to protect her
i think that in some way khan did the
[Music]
same
[Music]
it's godzilla
[Music]
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
there is something provoking him that
we're not seeing here by the same
opinion
the myths are real yeah there was a war
and they're the last one standing for
greatness
no one
[Music]
what are you doing oh i was just playing
with this lamp
i'm star short for star bruh assume
yours is barbara nope
just barb playing old barb
i want to thank barbara starr for
hosting tonight's talking club
and we're making their hot dog soup i
like the salt i like the hat dad
it's not as runny as it usually is
what does she drink i hope she gives me
bigger teeth love big teeth she loves
big teeth
even if it's just two eyes on a bunch of
teeth
my new phone case i love it it's like
i'm listening to the ocean wait we don't
have cell phones
i know i'm gonna take it home and glue
it to our landline
[Music]
i'm barb and this is star roll number
again please sir 6
11 six eleven oh my barb
oh my god she's six eleven six eleven
we're in 124.
oh
[Music]
there were hundreds of us working at
literary agencies
tabs wrong margins wrong really
everything wrong we answered calls for
our bosses
hello fetch them water never belying the
fact that
we wanted to be writers ourselves
guess who my boss represents and rice
the pope thomas pynchon
jd salinger no way he's still alive so
sallinger doesn't get any of his mail
not one you shred them did you send my
letter to mr salinger did you send my
letter to salinger
you can't read other people
m.a in english literature what do you
like to read
laurie hammett donald wesley to be in
this field
you'll need to read authors who are
alive you keep saying you want to write
but you work
long hours for other writers
dear boy from winston-salem if you want
to uphold the spirit of holden
try not to care too much about how
people judge you
sincerely joanna rakoff
these letters have changed me someone
should go to the meeting in washington
i suppose i could send me
you become quite the expert in what
salindr would say
you've crossed the line
[Music]
there's just things i want to do i'm
afraid that if i don't do them now i
never will
[Music]
you have good instincts you have it in
you to become a really
fine agent but you have other
aspirations
i didn't want to be ordinary
[Music]
i want to be extraordinary making noise
sounds like work no tell them i'm in my
chair
yes he's just walked in this is
unexpected
i can't believe i'm actually having
lunch with spies
i'm just a salesman exactly you're
civilians the kgb won't be watching
it would be a real service to great
britain
what would you want me to do
i'm here to open a door to the
top manufacturers in the west
[Music]
would i be putting myself in danger if
this mission was the least bit dangerous
you really are the last man we'd send
make sure you wear it while you're in
moscow
what does this do shoot poison dart
everyone you meet assume their kgb
every russian is an eye of the state
you'll just be a courier just a career
for russian sea
from now on you will be selling one
thing
the idea that you are an ordinary
businessman and nothing more than an
ordinary businessman
the weapons of war must be abolished
before they apologize
i'm asking you to stop going to moscow i
am asking you as your wife i didn't want
you to be involved
what if i get caught then execute be
correct
[Music]
we can't get him out if things were the
other way around and kopski would
abandon you he would never
leave me to die and i'm not leaving him
i'm volunteering to bring back the best
source of service intelligence you've
got at a time where russia and america
are on the brink of nuclear war
maybe we're only two people
but this is how things change
[Music]
5'6
[Music]
i met this girl hi hi uh i'm mark
dude i saw you last night you didn't
tell me anything about a girl this is
gonna sound really strange
i was wondering are you experiencing any
kind of temporal anomaly
listen we're stuck in a time loop you me
everybody same day's repeating over and
over again like in groundhog day
and edge of tomorrow except only me and
this girl margaret know about it then
you don't remember any of this because
your brain keeps getting erased
oh so what have you brought to with
infinite time oh you know like
solving crimes and teaching myself how
to drive
i thought so you're into her well like
i'm not not
into her ever wish today happened on a
different day
just hoping we could talk about your
future besides who knows what they want
to be when they're 17.
i do aerospace engineer specifically a
nasa mission specialist
wait like an astronaut because that's
cool
that's like uh most of life is just
junk and then there's these moments and
all the randomness turns into something
perfect
that is disturbingly inspirational what
if we found them all
all the perfect things we could collect
them like partners
oh yeah can i tell you a secret
maybe i don't have to pretend
what is this oh i dropped me
he made a map of us
i should go
we could get out of it are you really in
that much of a hurry
you don't actually think that this is
living do you
we have all the time in the world this
is not time
time is the stuff that when you spend it
you don't get it back i thought
everything was perfect
but there's more to the story
[Music]
i thought we'd have so much more time
[Music]
why do you keep closing your laptop
every time i walk by
you look stressed
[Music]
work's been uh crazy
i've always wanted to change the world
how
amazon is for drugs
but you can't buy drugs on the internet
what if you could
using bitcoin i just made 75 grand
in the last 90 minutes baby that's 1.2
million
a day
[Music]
this guy's the first millennial gangster
you gonna crack this the old-fashioned
way ancient potent
everything they know they learned off a
screen
not staring down the barrel of a gun
experience matters oh
when you snatch them up send me a fax
the dark neck something special came in
the mail
game is changing it's gonna be every
suburb in america
this website needs to be shut down
immediately
the one's gonna bring this brick down
you crossed this line and ain't no going
back
you're getting obsessive
we get him on conspiracy to commit
murder
checkmate come on hold your breath
what are you doing with my money
this thing is going to outlive all of us
[Music]
um
that kid is staring at us
[Music]
you're on my property uh do you know any
anything that might be open this way
like a motel or might be something
further north
nope sam did you leave the hazards did i
leave the hazards on
high we were just wondering if we could
borrow your phone
oh please please where are my manners
you two must be starving
room for dessert
there's no online phone service
over here
sam
[Music]
you like cardamom we were
but we have been given an opportunity
for
and solutions
all right guys remember what we're
looking for and don't
trust anyone
[Music]
hey baby where are your parents
hey uh who's baby
really a con baby
[Applause]
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up my name is raya
our lands have been at war for as long
as we can remember
our people never see eye to eye
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again
but someone has to take the first step
now in order to restore peace
we must find the last dragon i wish to
join this
fellowship of butt kickery
let's go we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
six years of searching please
let this be it almighty
who said that we really need your help
ah i'm gonna be real with you
i'm not like the best dragon have you
ever done like a group project but
there's like that one kid who didn't
pitch in as much but
still ended up with the same grave uh
we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're nuts
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
you just have to take the first step
i just shave change dragons can do that
look how close my butt is to my head
it's gonna make digestion so much faster
in theaters
or ordered on disney plus with premiere
access march 5th
[Music]
so so is daniel enjoying his summer
holidays not really
he was meant to be visiting his father
in florida but let's just say bob isn't
the most reliable
hello i'm afraid you're stuck with
boring old me for six weeks
but we'll have fun sorry to hear about
his trip
daniel seems quite philosophical about
it all though i don't want to be here do
i i'll be in florida where i'm supposed
to be
with dad i think he's quite disappointed
to be honest
he spends so much time on his own you
weren't exactly life and soul at his age
when was the last time he had a night
out just these three you wanted to
borrow
as it happens rather like to borrow you
for an evening too
why are we on the phone to my history
teacher we just had a bit of a flare
please stop talking now if it makes you
feel uncomfortable
it does then we can talk about it
talking about it makes me uncomfortable
do you smoke weed or the goths in my ear
smoke weed
i'm not goth well i knew then
if you actually thought anything
mattered you'd do something about it you
don't
because there's no point i just want to
understand you wouldn't so leave it
i just wanted us to do something fun but
you're right i should have known you
just be
rude and ungrateful it's not my fault
you're the most boring person in the
world we did once used to have quite a
nice time together you know
what you said earlier about why'd we
bother we're still here aren't we
we can't muck things up too badly
there is no greater scourge facing
america from within
the president takes the opioid crisis
very seriously
the kid got snagged at the border the
courier
took a year of undercover work to get
this far maybe it's dangerous to press a
big sale now
but what choice do we have
our product will be the first truly
non-addictive painkiller
what the hell is going on all the
addiction centers are lighting up and
then by day 10
they're dead
[Music]
i'm looking for my son were you aware of
any issues
with your son like what
based on your results you want
northlight to pull their billion-dollar
drug
it can cost you a hell of a lot more
than your teaching job
you've got to have a plan a plan for
telling the truth
careful should this kid get an itch to
name names
that would be unpleasant for everyone
what they're gonna come after you but
what you're doing now
may be the most important thing you ever
do
you had my son run drugs for you
this is the biggest public health crisis
since tobacco it's not our
responsibility then whose is
it you cannot walk into that buy alone
we can't quit we can't stop
what do you think we're here to do to
make a difference
we can touch you anywhere in the world
we're running out of time
last chance
[Music]
you